and I am now joined by the president of
the european commission ursula fonder
line welcome to the program and thank
you so much for joining us thank you
it's good to be with you on Monday the
European Union is joining forces with
global partners to raise 7.5 billion
euros in a worldwide pledging initiative
to support coronavirus diagnostics and
vaccines what is the top thing that you
hope to achieve well for us it's
important that we give a strong answer
to the coronavirus because we know it
knows no borders it knows no
nationalities and we can only defeat
that virus by a vaccine and for that we
need a global coordinated action because
we want to prevent that there is a run
to the vaccine once we have it for those
who can afford it so we need the
coordinated research on the vaccine when
we have it and we start right now
already we have to build up capacities
to manufacture it billions of doses and
then we have to make sure that we can
deploy to every corner in the world in a
fair and affordable price and that's
what exactly we're working on for that
we need money and we need to go global
cooperation we have this global
framework now and we need the pledging
conference on Monday to raise the 7.5
billion euros this is just the start I
think we will need more over time so you
say a fair and affordable price to it
for any potential vaccine but the UN
secretary-general has actually taken it
one step further when it comes to
facilitating public access to a vaccine
he says vaccines should belong to the
entire world not to individual countries
or regions or companies is that
something that you would be willing to
support should a vaccine belong to
humanity well of course everybody should
have access to this vaccine and that's
the reason why we got all the stakes
stakeholders that are necessary so we
have the whu-oh the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation the Wellcome Trust unit
8 Global Fund just to name some of
course these important platforms like
sepia and Gavi
and we're backed by many many countries
in the world the g20
I brought the initiative to the g20 so
this is necessary to really have a
global approach a coordinated approach
in this important task I'd like to ask
you because the crisis in the meantime
is really hitting the European economy
hard I mean many warnings that the EU
could risk doing too little too late to
shield the economy from the effects of
the coronavirus you're currently
figuring out how to finance the --use
coronavirus recovery fund but so far no
concrete plan has been put forward
where's the urgency well first of all
for the acute crisis we put forward the
European Union and the member states a
sum of three point four trillion which
is for example the flexible is a ssin of
state aid the flexible ization of all
the european funds but also a program to
keep people the employees in their
companies being paid for short time work
so that the healthy companies can
restart immediately the economy picks up
again this has been put out at a first
answer for the corona crisis but you're
right we need a big recovery instrument
and for that we proposed that we work on
the seven-year budget of the european
union topped by a recovery instrument
that is Marshall plan like which we can
then channel through the budget and give
it to the Member States because the
budget is per se an instrument for
investment for solidarity it's backed by
all 27 member states but also for
cohesion and conversion and therefore it
is so important to have this instrument
in place we're working on it right now
we got a strong backing by the European
Council that was necessary and good and
it's a big endeavor but I'm positive
that we're gonna deliver what could we
see in that instrument because I mean we
have southern states like Italy and
Spain calling for grants neutralised
debts so-called corona bonds that's
facing opposition from countries like
Germany in the Netherlands so what will
be in the fund will we see corona bonds
we see grants so in the whole instrument
we will have certainly the right balance
of loans and grants this is the process
where we have to negotiate with all 27
member states but it is important that
all agree that is it is the way forward
to take so all agree on working on the
7-year budget of the European Union plus
a recovery instrument and this is a
strong measure of course I think this is
democracy we have to speak about the
detailing out the taylormade programs
but all are do agree that it is
important to support countries that are
hardest hit by the virus and the
economic consequences another issue
which has come up in this coronavirus
crisis is the issue of European
fundamental principles and values and in
that context I would like to ask you if
you're concerned about the crisis being
used here in the European Union to limit
democratic rights in countries for
example like Hungary well many countries
about 20 countries took extraordinary
measures which is in a crisis okay
because you have to be fast and you have
to be able to act but they have to be
proportionate they have to be time
limited very clearly and they have to be
under democratic scrutiny and here we're
looking very closely to how these
measures are implemented when it comes
to the European values indeed the
freedom of speech the freedom of media
for example so we stand ready to
intervene immediately if this is not
appropriate and time limited but in the
moment of crisis we see as I said many
member states that are using these
extraordinary measures it has to be in
the right sense you mentioned that also
that it has to be in the right sense
after Hungary passed its emergency
coronavirus law on the 30th 30th of
March you said that coronavirus crisis
cannot be used to undercut democracy but
you didn't mention Hungary by name
you've come under criticism for that do
you regret not mentioning them by name
it
for us very important to look at every
member state in the same way it is true
that with Hungary we have difficult
experiences so there will be a lot of
scrutiny but I think fairness among all
Member States is important and the
approach that we guarantee the
fundamental rights of the European Union
that we stand up being the guardian of
the treaty we have to be completely
neutral towards the Member State but
ready to act when something goes in the
wrong direction and here I'm very clear
what I said already that we're ready to
act the moment we see that the
implementation of these measures is not
appropriate as a trained physician when
you look at the situation that the world
is facing when you look at the situation
that the European Union is facing are
you sometimes just dismayed when you
look around this corona crisis is
devastating but it shows two sides it
shows on the one hand that there are
lessons we have to learn for example I
think we need a way more robust and
transparent data reporting system for us
in the European Union but also globally
to be better prepared and to have an
early warning system the second is that
we see how important is to have sound
strong health care systems that can
absorb shocks and that can respond to
crises like this one and the third one
that I think is important for the
European level is that we will have to
improve the system that the European
level is able to by critical medical
goods like personal protective equipment
like masks and Bluffs or ventilators buy
them stock pilot and distributed to
those Member States who need it this was
not in place at the beginning of the
crisis we put it in place now and we
will certainly have a very close look at
it the good part that we saw over the
last weeks is an enormous grow of
solidarity when I saw the the Polish and
the Romanian doctors and nurses going to
Italy
Italy on the other hand sharing test
kits with other the Member States France
sending patients to Germany and Austria
France sending masks to Spain and Italy
so many many examples of solidarity that
is and was good to see and I think later
on drawing the lessons from the crisis
this is on the positive side well we
thank you so much for joining us to
share that President of the European
Commission
Ursula founder line thank you so much